El día 24 de abril del año 2023 no fue un
día cualquiera, fue una jornada que pasó
a la historia:
Por primera, en muchos, muchísimos siglos,
China dejó oficialmente de ser el país con
más habitantes del mundo.
Ese día la ONU declaró que en la siguiente
actualización de sus estimaciones demográficas,
la India le arrebataría a China el primer
puestos en el ranking de los países con mayor
población.
Es decir que la India ya es a todas luces
el país más poblado de todo el planeta.
Según Naciones Unidas, más de 1.425 millones
de personas viven hoy por hoy en la India,
una cifra que como veis se espera crezca hasta
casi los 1.700 millones para mediados de siglo.
Estos que veis en pantalla serán los nuevos
gigantes demográficos. Y como veis a la cabeza
de todos e llos, y por mucha diferencia, estará
la India.
Una economía emergente, con un discreto,
pero activo arsenal nuclear y un peso político
que en los últimos años ha comenzado a despegar.
Amigos, la India quiere capitalizar su estatus
como el país más poblado de la tierra y
por eso ahora está buscando, por ejemplo,
tener un puesto permanente en el Consejo de
seguridad de la ONU.
Ahora bien, si en lugar de mirar al exterior
nos concentramos en el interior del país,
nos vamos a encontrar con realidades muy distintas.
Por ejemplo, el sistema de castas de este
país es una especie de misterio popular.
Se sabe mucho de su existencia pero no tanto
de su funcionamiento ni tampoco de sus consecuencias.
Porque sí, en cierta forma el sistema de
castas sigue existiendo por mucho que hace
ya décadas que la ley lo pusiera en la diana.
Y eso ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos hagamos
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Hasta qué punto sigue operando el sistema
de castas? ¿Cómo funciona exactamente en
la India moderna? ¿Puede ser este fenómeno
una especie de talón de Aquiles capaz de
evitar que el país más superpoblado del
mundo pueda prosperar?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, en este nuevo
vídeo de VisualPolitik vamos a buscar todas
las respuestas.
Arranquemos.
(INTRO)
Últimamente, la India se está poniendo de
moda y ya comienza a protagonizar grandes
titulares como estos:
N1 (11 de abril de 2022: La India quiere un
papel clave en la cadena de suministro a medida
que las empresas se mudan de China. Bloomberg)
N1.2(30 april 2023: Por qué todo el mundo
en el ámbito empresarial adora la India en
estos momentos. CNN)
N1.3 (21 junio 2023: El legendario inversor
en mercados emergentes Mark Mobius, conocido
por sus opiniones alcistas sobre China, se
fija ahora en la India. Business Insider)
Además, esta superpotencia emergente cuenta
con un sistema político relativamente estable:
desde el año 2004 hasta ahora, solo han ejercido
la jefatura del gobierno dos primeros ministros:
Manmohan Singh y Narendra Modi, del Congreso
Nacional Indio y el Partido Popular Indio,
respectivamente.
Es decir, que más allá de lo más o menos
controvertidas que puedan ser estas figuras
políticas, lo cierto es que el sistema de
gobierno parece bastante estable y predecible…
2 ingredientes muy apreciados por los inversores
extranjeros.
Así que en otras palabras: la India parece
tener todos los rasgos de una potencia en
ascenso: una economía en marcha, un arsenal
militar creciente, un rol geopolítico clave
entre Occidente y Oriente, y además una relación
razonablemente buena con Washington, con Moscú
e, incluso, con Pekín. [Al menos todo lo
buenas que podrían ser si tenemos en cuenta
los históricos recelos entre los dos gigantes
asiáticos.]
Sin embargo, no sé, hay algo que nos suena
raro. Lo de querer ser una potencia en ascenso
que, además, aspire a lograr el mismo éxito
económico que tuvieron los dragones asiáticos
y luego al mismo tiempo mantener un sistema
que clasifica a la población según a qué
casta o linaje pertenezca, no casa nada, pero
que nada bien, ¿no os parece?
Pero, ¿qué son exactamente las castas?
Pues básicamente hablamos, por así decirlo,
de la madre de todas las burocracias.
Un orden social del que resulta muy difícil
escapar. Una forma de organización social
muy antigua - podemos rastrear su existencia
hasta 3.000 años antes de Cristo. Pues bien,
este sistema consiste en dividir a las personas
en diferentes grupos sociales conocidos como
"castas" y es hereditario. Es decir, uno si
uno nace en una casta, por lo general permanece
en ella por el resto de su vida.
Originalmente, las castas se definieron a
través del "varna", una palabra en lengua
sánscrita que se traduce como "color", aunque
en este caso no se refiere a la piel sino
a la clasificación social. Una clasificación
que tradicionalmente condicionaba toda tu
vida: los trabajos que podías desempeñar,
con quién te podías emparentar, tu rol en
la sociedad, etcétera, etcétera.
De esta forma se intenta - o al menos se intentaba
- estructurar a toda la sociedad.
C1 (“Los hindúes dividen a las personas
según sus vidas pasadas. En la cima están
los Brahmanes los sacerdotes y los eruditos.
Luego los Chatrias son los gobernantes y los
soldados. Debajo de ellos están los Vaishyas,
esto es, los mercaderes y los comerciantes.
Y luego los shudras, los trabajadores. Por
último, los dalits o parias que son los intocables,
considerados impuros y sucios, son indignos
de pertenecer a cualquier casta. Por tradición
son el eslabón mas bajo. Reportaje de Naciones
Unidas sobre los Intocables)
El caso es que todas las personas que nacen
en una casta particular tienen ya un rol asignado
en su vida social. Es decir, que se enfrentan
a escalones sociales y económicos ya predeterminados.
Y ojo porque hablamos de una clasificación
que, aparte de los cuatro grandes grupos,
en realidad está dividida en cerca de 3.000
castas y casi 25.000 subcastas. Y luego están
las tribus, que vienen a ser otra clasificación,
y luego las personas que se quedan fuera de
este sistema y que forman lo que se conoce
como los intocables, el estrato más bajo
de toda la sociedad.
Personas que estaban obligadas a realizar
trabajos considerados "sucios" o "impuros"
y que eran frecuentemente excluidas socialmente.
Por supuesto, como ya os podéis imaginar,
semejantes engranajes sociales tienen un coste
de oportunidad enorme. Durante siglos este
sistema ha limitado el ascensor social como
ningún otro.
Afortunadamente hoy ya en declive… Aunque
como veremos la sociedad india todavía no
ha conseguido librarse por completo de él.
De hecho, para muchos sigue siendo un grave
problema para las aspiraciones de la India.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Para entender toda esta
historia tenemos que echar la vista ligeramente
hacia atrás. Tenemos que ver cómo y cuándo
comenzó a combatirse este perverso sistema.
Así… Vamos con ello.
T1 (DEL DICHO, ¿AL HECHO?)
Queridos amigos, durante la vigencia del [rách]
Raj británico, los propios agentes europeos
incorporaron el sistema de castas indio en
su sistema de gobierno. Lo utilizaban, por
ejemplo, para asignar los diferentes cargos
en las instituciones locales.
Claro que, hacia 1920, los propios británicos
comenzar a limitar su uso, en parte para frenar
el creciente descontento hacia la corona.
Lógicamente, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Eso de nacer pobre y no poder tener esperanzas
en mejorar tu situación, o tener que resignarte
a tener una vida muy similar a la de tus padres,
no es plato de buen gusto para nadie.
Pero eso fue solo el comienzo. Cuando la India
logró por fin sellar su independencia, se
planteó una Constitución que fue de frente
contra este sistema de castas. Su artículo
15 decía exactamente esto:
C1.2(“El Estado no discriminará a ningún
ciudadano únicamente por motivos de religión,
raza, casta, sexo, lugar de nacimiento o cualquiera
de ellos”. Artículo 15 de la Constitución
de India de 1949)
La construcción de la nueva nación, por
fin liberada del colonialismo inglés, fue
liderada en su mayor parte por las castas
de más alto rango, las cuales tienen el rol,
precisamente, de conducir los asuntos de Estado.
Pero, pese a ello ya lo veis, en la propia
Constitución señalaron al sistema de castas,
prohibiendo al Estado que tomara decisiones
en base a esta terrible clasificación social.
Un primer paso para acabar con ella.
El problema es que esta es una de esas cosas
que es más fácil de decir que de hacer.
(Desde entonces, gobierno tras gobierno, las
autoridades indias han tratado de desmontar
la rígida estratificación social que vivía
el país. En 1955, por ejemplo, se promulgó
la Ley de Intocabilidad que reglamentaba como
delito la discriminación por casta en espacios
laborales o educativos. En 1976, se amplió
el alcance de esta ley, rebautizándola la
como Ley de Protección de los Derechos Civiles.
Y así se fueron aprobando un popurri de nuevas
normas, leyes y disposiciones, hasta que en
1979 se produjo un punto de inflexión: el
establecimiento de la Comisión de Clases
Social y Educativam ente AtrasadaS, o como
popularmente se le conoce, la comisión Mandal.)
Esta comisión le debe su nombre a Babu Bindheshwari
Prasad Mandal, un político originario de
una de las castas más poderosas del país,
que recibió la misión del gobierno del primer
ministro, Morarji Desai, de elaborar un informe
que analizara la situación de las castas,
y esbozara un paquete de políticas para poder
revertir de cuajo toda esta enorme estratificación
social.
Pues bien, el informe se terminó en 1980,
y fue presentado a la entonces primera ministra
Indira Gandhi, lo que abrió un feroz debate
político y social.
El informe básicamente consideraba que pese
a todas las prohibiciones legales, el sistema
de castas seguía en pie clasificando y regulando
la vida de decenas y decenas, cientos de millones
de indios.
Además, denunciaba que por culpa de las castas,
muchos grupos sociales se habían quedado
terriblemente atrás, condenados a vivir en
la más abyecta pobreza.
Y, ojo, porque no hablamos de poca gente.
Según este mismo informe, las personas que
formaban parte de las castas o las clases
más bajas y, por tanto, eran las más perjudicadas
por un sistema que de hecho las despreciaba,
sumaban cerca del 50% de toda la población
del país.
Pues bien, para intentar revertir esta situación,
la comisión Mandal hizo algunas recomendaciones,
como por ejemplo, incidir en los sistemas
de cupos y reservar al menos el 27% de los
trabajos públicos y las plazas educativas
para personas que formaran parte de las clases
sociales atrasadas que no estuvieran ya protegidas.
El problema es que el coste de semejante plan,
y sobre todo la resistencia de diferentes
sectores políticos a la hora de aceptar como
válido este informe, retrasaron la adopción
de las diferentes recomendaciones que se hacían.
Y así fue hasta que en 1989 el gobierno indio
promulgó la Ley de Castas y Tribus Registradas,
endureciendo aún más las medidas contra
esta especie de clasismo social.
Además, en 1990 el gobierno comenzó a implementar
las recomendaciones de la Comisión Mandal.
Algo que, por cierto, desató grandes protestas
por lo que se consideraba un claro atropello
a los principios meritocráticos del Estado
indio.
Al final, las cosas se torcieron tanto que
el propio Primer Ministro terminó renunciando
en noviembre de ese mismo año, lo que hizo
que se reconsiderara el sistema de cupos y
reservas.
Pero ahí no se terminó la controversia.
Amigos, la polémica llegó a la Corte Suprema
de la India.
En 1992 este órgano determinó que se creara
la Comisión Nacional de Clases Atrasadas,
y que se avanzara en las medidas dictadas
por el informe de la Comisión Mandal, favoreciendo,
eso sí, las medidas corte social y educativo.
Desde entonces, la Comisión Nacional de Clases
Atrasadas funciona como un organismo ejecutivo
a través del cual c ada gobierno canaliza
sus medidas contra el sistema de castas.
Es decir, que el gobierno indio lleva años
luchando contra este sistema. La pregunta,
¿realmente ha logrado erradicarlo? ¿Qué
impacto siguen teniendo las castas en la India?
¿Por qué muchos analistas piensan que aún
pueden ser una trabaja para el despegue económico
de este país?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (LAS CASTAS EN EL SIGLO XXI)
Ya lo habéis visto, en los últimos años,
todos los gobiernos han tratado de luchar
contra el sistema de castas pero lo cierto
es que este en cierta forma… Aún sobrevive.
Parece que 3, 4 o 5 décadas no han sido suficientes
para echar abajo una tradición con más de
3.000 años de antigüedad.
(En 2011, por ejemplo, el censo social y económico
todavía mostraba que 4 de cada 10 indios
estaban clasificados como parte de las clases
más bajas.
Y no solo eso, luego las castas más bajas
y las tribus registradas, que son grupos que
también son en mayor o menor medida desfavorecidos
y discriminados socialmente, sumaban casi
otro 30% de la población.
Solo las castas generales son aquellas que
no sufren prejuicios o tienen privilegios.
Y como podéis ver, en 2011 apenas suponían
el 30,7% de la población. Era - y sigue siendo
- el grupo privilegiado a costa, en gran medida
del resto del país.)
Pero, no tenemos que irnos tan atrás. Evidentemente,
las cosas ya no están tan mal, pero en 2021,
este sistema seguía teniendo, por ejemplo,
mucha incidencia en la pobreza.
A nivel de salud, nutrición, años de escolarización,
saneamientos, o vivienda, lo miremos por dónde
lo miremos, pertenecer a una casta o a una
tribu de nivel bajo o a los intocables sigue
siendo sinónimo de muchos más problemas
y peores condiciones de vida. Es decir, la
brecha no se ha cerrado, y si no se ha cerrado
es porque la influencia de este sistema todavía
persiste.
C2 (“En total, cinco de cada seis personas
en situación de pobreza multidimensional
en la India viven en hogares encabezados por
una persona perteneciente a una tribu registrada,
una casta registrada u otra clase atrasada”
Índice de Pobreza Multidimensional (IPM)
2021)
Y, ojo, porque si la población india supera
los 1.400 millones de habitantes, hablamos
de que cerca de 1.000 millones de personas
lo tienen más difícil que el resto por una
simple cuestión de linaje.
Y no me refiero al patrimonio de las familias,
sino a su capacidad para escalar puestos profesionales,
sociales e, incluso, políticos, conforme
a sus propios méritos. ¡De locos!
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Justo aquí es cuando llegamos
a la parte clave de este vídeo. Pese a todos
los avances logrados por la creciente persecución
del gobierno, el principal problema que sigue
causando toda esta estratificación social
tiene que ver, precisamente, con la pérdida
de capital humano que conlleva. Y no olvidemos
que el capital humano es una variable absolutamente
indispensable para que un país logre desarrollarse.
Queridos amigos, amigas, podemos estar hablando
de un coste de oportunidad gigantesco, tanto
para los indios como para el resto del mundo.
Atentos.
T3 (EL POTENCIAL EN LAS SOMBRAS)
Cuando echamos un vistazo al sistema educativo
indio, lo primero con que nos encontramos
en primaria y secundaria, es que la diferencia
entre los diferentes grupos sociales es también
bastante notable: tres cuartas partes de los
estudiantes forman parte de los intocables
o de las castas y las tribus desfavorecidas
socialmente.
Lo cual tiene sentido. Las familias más pobres
siguen teniendo más hijos, y ya hemos visto
que el sistema de castas sigue teniendo mucha
incidencia en los datos de pobreza.
Pues bien, sea como sea, el problema es que
esto también condiciona su rendimiento educativo.
Los niños de estas familias tienen tasas
de fracaso escolar más altas. Lo que evidentemente
supone un enorme coste de oportunidad.
Sí, es verdad que los datos han mejorado
década tras década, pero todavía existen
diferencias significativas. Y si nos vamos
a los niveles superiores las diferencias son
más abultadas.
Y es que, amigos, aquí nos encontramos con
dos caras totalmente diferentes:
Por un lado, la India es, según la Unesco,
el país que más cantidad de estudiantes
tiene en secundaria, cómo podéis ver prácticamente
dobla a China. Y eso es una gran noticia.
Una población más formada suele traducirse
en mejores puestos de trabajo y un desarrollo
más rápido.
Y no solo eso. La India también es uno de
los países del mundo donde los estudiantes
universitarios se inclinan más por las carreras
de ciencias, tecnología, ingeniería y matemáticas.
Fijaos.
Sin embargo, por otra parte, por culpa del
sistema de castas, es muy probable que cerca
de la mitad de todos estos estudiantes de
secundaria que hemos mencionado no puedan
acceder a estudios universitarios o una formación
profesional de calidad. Lo que supone un enorme
desperdicio de talento.
De hecho, este dichoso sistema de clasificación
social sigue tan arraigado que sus efectos
incluso han llegado a los mismísimos Estados
Unidos. Y no a cualquier parte. Se sospecha
que incluso empieza a tener alguna incidencia
en el mismísimo Silicon Valley.
Un momento, ¿pensáis que nos hemos vuelto
locos? ¿Estados Unidos? ¿Castas?... Pues
fijaos, porque eso exactamente lo que explica
noticias como estas:
N2 (Los ingenieros de la India han prosperado
en Silicon Valley. También lo ha hecho su
sistema de castas. Washington Post)
N3 (Cómo las grandes tecnológicas están
importando el legado de castas de la India
a Silicon Valley. El año pasado, un graduado
dalit de IIT Bombay presentó una demanda
en EE. UU. contra Cisco Systems Inc. y dos
de sus compañeros, diciendo que había sufrido
discriminación basada en la casta. Bloomberg)
Vale, puede que quizás sean solo un par de
casos aislados, o quizás no, porque lo cierto
es que en los últimos años docenas de ingenieros
indios que trabajan en el extranjero, sobre
todo en Estados Unidos, han llevado este tema
a los tribunales.
Lo que, bueno, noE sé, como mínimos, podemos
decir que resulta muy significativo.
De hecho, esta exportación cultural, tan
digamos, … Particular, podría tener su
origen en los Institutos Indios de Administración
y en los Institutos Indios de Tecnología.
Estas instituciones fueron creadas por el
gobierno indio en los años 60 y hoy son la
crème de la crème del sistema universitario.
Pues bien, pese a que cuentan con un sistema
de cupos para que accedan algunos estudiantes
de las castas más desfavorecidas, lo cierto
es que mayoritariamente están copados por
los grupos sociales más, digamos, privilegiados.
Amigos, amigas, el sistema de castas está
formalmente perseguido desde los años 70,
pero a pesar de ello sigue teniendo una enorme
influencia en la sociedad indica. Las familias
de linaje “más bajo” conforme a este
sistema tienden a ser más pobres, sus hijos
tienen mayor tasa de fracaso escolar y muchas
más dificultades para que les contraten en
un buen trabajo. Es por así decirlo una mancha
que los acompaña de por vida.
Por supuesto, esto puede provocar muchos problemas:
desigualdad, frustración e, incluso, con
el tiempo, también conflictividad social.
Parece mentira, pero este todavía es un tema
que en la India se tienen que tomar muy en
serio.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta es
para ti:
¿Qué os parece este peculiar sistema de
clasificación social? ¿Por qué creéis
que ningún gobierno ha logrado erradicarlo?
¿Qué tendrían que hacer para acabar con
él de una vez por todas?
Como siempre déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios. Y ahora si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.